pour la plupart des gens les sorcières
n'existe que dans les contes de fées
et puis un jour elle se pointe chez vous
les manchots enfants
c'est là qu'on intervient je m'appelle
gretel et lui c'est mon frère en scène
on tue les sorcières et vous êtes moins
créé par un bout
ces deux dernières semaines cinq enfants
nous ont été enlevés je ne vais pas vous
laisser me dire ce que je peux faire
face à des monstres
autant d'enfants enlevés aussi
facilement une sorcière ne se montre pas
rocquelin jours comme ça
sauf si elle y est obligé
sont pas des sorcières que nos chasseurs
on a fait un autre chose
une blague
je vois que j'ai reçu mon invitation
aïe
elles ont ma soeur vraiment signal
déchaîner les enfers
attendez c'est quoi le signale à ces
camps j'exposerai une de 16 heures de
garde
ça c'est nouveau certains diront que
toutes les sorcières ne sont pas
mauvaises
leurs pouvoirs peuvent servir à faire le
bien
moi je dis qu'on les brûle d'hôtes
elle a l'air en colère ouais si j'avais
sa tête moi aussi je serais en colère tu
veut la fermer